the scenes are increasingly familiar
another day of canceled trains
frustrated passengers and widespread
disruption today it was the turn of the
train drivers Union as left to bring the
country to a halt in a strike affecting
11 train lines across Britain I have I
am home to see my son for
to home so yeah it's affected
effectively lost out on a day with my
son the strikes generally like oh God I
hate the strikes or do you kind of
understand why they're doing it I Toshi
understand why they're doing it just not
on the day that I have my hand too no
you can't say that it's just the latest
in a long line of strikes set to
continue in the run-up to Christmas
the strikes have revolved around the
same issue all year pay the unions want
a settlement that better reflects
soaring inflation the government says
train drivers are already very well paid
an average of 59 000 pounds a year and
that they need to work with rather than
against train companies but the longer
the dispute runs the greater the cost to
the economy the center for economics and
business research has calculated that by
January train strikes alone will of
course the British economy nearly 700
million pounds
says a pay rise shouldn't be Beyond
train companies that continue to make
profits the same companies they make 500
million during a pandemic when we
weren't getting pay Rises they're being
paid not to run trains and I will bet
that they all declare a profit they
share and pay a dividends to their
shareholders so it seems to be that
while they're being paid to run trains
they expect that the people to work for
them not to achieve anything at all in a
separate but related dispute the largest
transport Union the rmt is planning
eight more days of strike action in
December and January but there are signs
the mood music might be changing what
are the chances of getting a deal do you
think the rmt met the transport
secretary Mark Harper this week and
afterwards both sounded more positive
than they have in months I think there
was a shared agreement that this dispute
has gone on for too long
um ala I think it would be good if we
could resolve the dispute at the
earliest possible opportunity both for
the benefit of the people that work in
the industry but also very importantly
for the passing changes who want a good
a well well-run Railway progress perhaps
but until deals are actually done
widespread disruption is set to continue
Matthew Thompson Sky News